I've tried sorry to be a serious artist
and no one listens to my music no one
cared then we filmed these Vines and the
first one got posted and it got like
maybe one or two million in the first
couple days and I was like what the hell
is going on here I spent my whole life
making art nobody cares and somehow now
this I didn't even have to try I just
show up looking silly and that's what
people want to see and all of a sudden
it started working yeah the bull cut was
the haircut I had my whole life growing
up I was too scared to get any other
haircut the ski jacket I stole from my
mom the glasses were like the glasses I
wear as a kid that made me feel cool the
jinko jeans were like the pants that I
always wanted I pulled all that together
my friend looked right through me he
didn't even know it was me and then he
was like no way we gotta go film some
Vines it was like back in the vine era
and this is after I had already gone
through like failed record career failed
like so much stuff that